now  behold  he's here he's here  father is here the kingman lady the king  your fake is set and you cannot escape  it  now i've missed you my son  one day this kingdom will be yours  thank you father  my king  [Music]  father  remember  foreign  [Music]  you mother i won't kill your fueler  why would they stow away to such a  hellish place  to find what was stolen from me  and what is that  the kingdom  you must choose between kindness for  your kin  or hate for your enemies  your strength breaks man's bones  i have the cunning to break their minds  and night by night we will carry out my  pledge of vengeance  i will avenge you father  i will kill you  [Music]  you